DAVID SYMONDS: Thank you
very much for coming.
How about we give our
gopher dancers a
big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID SYMONDS: This is High
Performance Apps with Go on
App Engine.
Thank you very much
for coming.
My name is David Symonds.
I am an engineer on the Go team
at Google, and I lead the
Technical Development for the
Go runtime for App Engine.
As you might tell for
my accent, I'm
not from around here.
I'm from the Sydney office.
So here's what we're going
to cover today.
I'm just going to give
you a brief overview
of Go on App Engine.
Hopefully many of you here
have tried it out at one
stage, just to give you a feel
for where we're at and give
you a bit of an overview of
a couple of relatively
high-profile apps that
are using it.
Then I'm going to introduce a
motivating example for what
we're going to use to explore
some performance techniques
for your app.
And then the rest of the
session, which will be most of
the time, I'll be talking
about those performance
techniques in some detail.
So why Go on App engine?
First of all, it's got the
peanut butter and the
chocolate in a great
combination.
Go compiles to native code.
It runs really fast.
It's a fantastic programming
environment to work in.
At the same time, App Engine is
a fantastic platform as a
service you can use to
host your web app.
It auto scales.
It's very, very low
maintenance.
I don't like getting woken up
at 3:00 AM to fix things.
I imagine neither do you.
So if you're hosting on App
Engine, we have people at
Google who will wake up at 3:00
AM to fix problems when
they happen.
Combining these two together, we
get the fastest runtime for
App Engine.
It starts really fast.
It runs really fast.
It keeps your instance
hours down low.
It's cheap for what it does.
And you've got code running at
full machine speed so you can
do sophisticated, actual
processing, not
just serving text.
So we first unveiled the Go
runtime for App Engine here at
Google I/O two years ago.
And since then, we've seen
a lot of people adopt it.
It's grown over time.
It's supporting more of
the App Engine APIs.
It's got better tooling.
And we're seeing steady
growth and several
high-profile users.
Now, I wanted to talk about two
that Google has done to
give you a feel for
what's possible.
These are by no means hugely
sophisticated apps.
But they're kind of
representative of things that
are easy and natural to do in Go
that might be a little bit
harder in other languages.
But they really show off the
power and speed you can get.
The first one is a front page of
google.com, a Turkey Doodle
from Thanksgiving
two years ago.
This is an interesting
one because it was
written by a Go newcomer.
He'd never written any Go code
before, but he picked it up,
and he got this high-profile
app to
launch in under 24 hours.
So if you're thinking to
yourself, I love App Engine,
but I'm a Python, or Java
programmer, or maybe a PHP
programmer now.
What's Go got in for me?
Maybe it's too hard to learn.
This is great evidence that
you can get from 0 to 100
miles per hour with not
too much difficulty.
Go's really easy to pick up.
When this person built it, this
app is doing some image
compositing.
So you can see it's rendering
a graphic of a turkey with
different feathers.
You can see it animated from
that link down below.
But it's doing image
work here.
It's not just serving
static images.
It's doing sophisticated
stuff.
And this Go newcomer found that
he could build this app
relatively easily and get half
the latency of an equivalent
Python 2.7 version.
As you can imagine, watching it
on google.com, the homepage
produces a fair bit of
traffic, and this
didn't miss a beat.
And there's some more details
of how well it
performed at that link.
Santa Tracker for last year
was written in Go.
And this was the component that
kept track of where Santa
was and informed the client-side
JavaScript where
to render Santa and how
many presents he had
delivered, and so forth.
It served a peak of nearly 5,000
QPS, so 5,000 queries
per second.
This is also a very
high-pressure situation.
If things aren't going right, he
can't just tell people come
back tomorrow for something
like this.
It's too late by then.
We didn't make any
children cry.
And you can see down at the
bottom, we did this with under
80 instances.
So this is a lot fewer than you
might expect for this kind
of query volume.
So let me introduce to
you Gopher Mart.
Gopher Mart is a little sample
app, and I'll have a link at
the end of this presentation
for source code for it.
It's a bit of a silly app.
But it kind of demonstrates
enough of the features for us
to discuss building a really
high-performance app.
So here's the situation.
Imagine you are running an app
to manage or to run, indeed,
your Gopher Mart, which is your
one-stop shop for all
your gopher needs.
You gophers can come in, get
their gopher bran, their
gopher flakes, their gopher
liter, load them up in a cart,
take them to a checkout, and
then take them home obviously.
And the correspondence to an app
that we're going to use is
that the gophers that are doing
the shopping are your
user requests.
Each of your checkout
gophers--
the gophers processing each
of those requests--
is an app instance.
And then there's the scheduler
gopher that's got a direct
user request to app instances.
A checkout gopher can
only deal with one
request at a time.
And checkout gophers can be
hired or fired in our Gopher
Mart, but there is a certain
overhead to this.
This models how we deal with
App Engine instances.
They take a little bit
of time to start up.
They're very quick to start up
and go, but it's still a
nonzero amount of time.
And they can't be fired
straight away.
Our Gopher Mart has serious
industrial relations laws.
You need to keep your checkout
gophers around for at least 15
minutes after they've
been hired.
But as in our Gopher Mart, our
gophers don't want to be
standing in queue with
their gopher bran.
They want to get home and eat
their gopher bran-- pour
gopher milk all over it, scoop
it out of their gopher bowls.
They don't want to be standing
in queues waiting
for all this to happen.
They'll get kind of grumpy
if we take too long.
So we're going to look at
different ways of making our
app really fly.
I'm going to be looking at five
different techniques.
But before we look at any
techniques, we have to
understand the way
that we approach
high-performance apps.
And it's very easy to fool
ourselves into thinking that
we know where the
slow bits are.
Whenever you're doing
performance work, you need to
first measure to understand
where the slow bits are.
There's no point of spending
months of your time tuning,
and tweaking, and caching, and
doing all kinds of things to
one bit of code if that bit of
code isn't your slow bit.
So you need to measure first.
It's also important to
measure periodically.
Your app will behave differently
based on different
request loads, different types
of request processing, what
you're trying to do
in each request.
So it's important to come back
to measuring how fast it is
over time because it will change
as you change your app.
Even if you don't change your
app, the infrastructure
underneath will change over time
as well and almost always
for the better.
So App Engine gets better
at scheduling
instances to app servers.
It'll get better at getting
files to the app servers,
starting them up quickly,
and so on.
Go got a lot faster.
Just a few days ago when we
announced Go 1.1, that was
major milestone, our second
major stable release, that
brought a lot of performance
improvements.
We got emails to the mailing
list about people seeing their
programs written in Go dropping
from like 24 hours
runtime to 9 hours runtime.
So there's startling differences
in every release
of things, so you need to
periodically come back to
remeasure your app to understand
what bits are slow
and what bits aren't.
The tool that we're going to be
using to get a feel for how
our app performs is
called Appstats.
And what Appstats does is it
traces API RPCs over the
course of requests.
It measures the start time and
the stop time, what these
requests are doing, and also
records the stack trace so you
can dig in through a web
interface to be able to see
where this RPC came from, how
long it took, any errors that
happened, and so on.
And as you can see here, here's
a -- timeline, with
time running along
the x-axis--
of my first version
of this app.
Now, I wrote it as simply as
possible with no thoughts to
performance, just simplicity.
And you can see it's
pretty slow.
It's taking nearly
400 milliseconds.
And what it's doing
is, the gopher
comes up to the checkout.
The checkout gopher has to scan
each item that was in
their cart, and then emails
them a receipt afterwards.
This is a fairly modern
Gopher Mart.
So instead of just giving them
a printed receipt, they'll
just get it in their email
later on that day.
So we're going to look
at different ways of
speeding this up.
So I'm going to be
covering five
performance techniques today.
These aren't comprehensive.
There's plenty more that you
can think of, and each one,
I'll be only giving a bit of a
flavor for the depth that you
can go into to fully realize
these techniques.
But these should be five
fairly representative
techniques of how to
tackle these kind
of performance problems.
First one to do is
deferring work.
Not all work needs to be done
during the request.
In our Gopher Mart situation
when the gophers come up to
the checkout and are checking
out their items, they don't
need the email of the receipt
right then and there.
They're going to take their cart
out to their gopher car,
load up the gopher boot with
their gopher bran, drive to
the gopher home.
It's going to take them
a little while.
So the importance of getting the
mail out to them straight
away is not so important.
And in general, a lot of web
apps need to do things as a
consequence of a request, but
don't need to do them during
the request.
So this may seem like a pretty
simplistic technique, and
we'll get on to slightly more
sophisticated ones shortly.
But it's an important
one to remember.
Lots of the time, you can
forget that you're doing
things that you don't
need to be doing.
The main ways that we're going
to going do this with the Go
App Engine API is with the Task
Queue API or the delay
package that is built over
the Task Queue API.
And we're going to use this to
shift work that it needs to do
outside the request scope.
In our Gopher Mart situation,
we're going to shift that slow
mail lots end call that took a
large chunk of our timeline.
And we're going to do that in a
task that's going to happen
usually very soon afterwards.
But we're going to replace
it with a very quick
taskqueue.add.
And we're going to use
the delay package.
And here's how the delay package
works in case you
haven't seen it before.
What it does is it
wraps a function.
You just go to try and
invoke that function.
And what it'll do behind the
scenes is it will marshall the
function arguments, store them
in a Task Queue task, add it
to the queue, and then when it
comes back, it'll invoke your
function for you.
So it's a very, very simple way
of dealing with Task Queue
when you're doing it
to defer work.
So you can see at the top, two
lines of my code for my simple
version there's a sendReceipt
function invocation.
And then you can see just the
function signature of
sendReceipt.
It's fairly simple.
All we have to do to use the
delay package is import
appengine/delay.
And then we turn our sendReceipt
invocation to
stick a dot Call in there.
Nothing else has to
change there.
Then we turn our function
definition into a variable
definition.
And we just use delay.func, give
it a name, and then we
have our function body
exactly as is.
So there's no difference from
what we were doing before.
And you can see the effect
that it has.
It shrunk that mail.send call.
It be a bit slow, and it might
be waiting on the mail
protocol to start so it can
verify that it can send mail,
spam filters, whatever it is.
And it's turned into a very
quick Task Queue call.
So this is a lot quicker, and
then the mail will happen in
its own Task Queue request.
Second technique I want to
talk about is batching.
In our Gopher Mart scenario,
it kind of makes sense that
you don't want a family of
10 gophers all going in
individually, picking up their
own box of gopher flakes,
walking up to the counter, each
going through the process
of checking them out, paying
for them, and then walking
home with them.
It makes a lot more sense for
one of the gophers to go in by
themselves, load up their cart
with 10 boxes of gopher
flakes, and then check
them out all at once.
And again, this is a relatively
simple technique,
but it's often overlooked.
This would be using API calls
like GetMulti instead of Get,
or PutMulti instead of Put.
Often they're a little bit
more overhead than just a
single call if you've only
got a single object.
But a lot time, you're dealing
with multiple entities.
And so they can be a lot quicker
because you only have
one lot of the RPC overhead
instead of in.
So here you can see the
code that I wrote
for the simple version.
You can see that it's just
sitting in a loop.
And for each key it goes and
fetches the item corresponding
to that key from
the data store.
It deals with any error, and
then just builds up a slice of
those items.
That's obviously very simple
to understand and to reason
about, but it's slow.
And here's what we do
when we batch it.
Instead of a loop where we're
doing each data store call, we
use datastore.GetMulti.
We tell it all the keys to go
and get, and then it returns
all the items for us.
And you can see, in this case,
the task you call was very
luckily short.
But more importantly the
datastore.Get call turned from
five sequential calls into
just one short one.
So we've already cut down our
program's request processing
time dramatically.
Third technique I want to
talk about is caching.
And I'm sure many of you have
cached things in the past.
And in our Gopher Mart scenario,
this would be like a
checkout gopher remembering
that for a certain fresh
fruit-- which might not have bar
codes, and they normally
have to look up a
booklet for--
they just remember gopher
berries, 361.
Gopher bananas, 492.
They can just remember these
things once they've been
running for a while, and they
can be a lot quicker.
But the first layer
that I want to
talk about is Datastore.
And Datastore is a great
storage system.
It's very fast.
It's very reliable.
It's highly scalable.
But it also can be
used as a cache.
So your program might be doing
expensive computation work.
It might be compositing
images.
It might be fetching a request
via URL fetch from a remote
server that's slow.
It could be doing any number of
things outside itself that
it has very little control over
that can be quite slow.
We can stick those in the
Datastore, and then all our
app instances can check the
Datastore before trying to do
that expensive computation
or remote fetch.
One thing even faster than
Datastore is Memcache.
And as opposed to Datastore
where a small Get might take
20 milliseconds--
thereabouts--
Memcache can do it in
about 1 millisecond.
So it can often be 20 times
faster for small workloads.
That's great.
It's shared across all
your instances.
You know, one of your checkout
gophers needs to look up the
code for gopher berries.
It stores it in your Memcache,
and every other checkout
gopher suddenly gets the benefit
of that caching.
You need to remember that,
unlike Datastore, Memcache is
not guaranteed to hang around.
It's not a persistent storage
system so it could get flushed
any time your app has been using
Memcache too much or
your App Engine infrastructure
moves your app to
another data center.
So you can't depend
on it being there.
But it's a great way of keeping
hot used data at
immediate access.
Third thing to use, and
something that might be quite
foreign to particularly
Python programmers,
is using local memory.
Your app is running as a program
on a real machine.
And we can easily forget about
that with our abstract notions
of the App Engine set up, and
instances, and requests, and
it all feels very abstract.
And we forget that they're
programs running on a machine
and that machine has memory.
So we can use local memory
in your app instance.
It would just be sticking things
in a global variable,
for example.
And that's even faster.
That's three orders of magnitude
faster than Memcache
will usually be for
small amounts.
It's even more fragile than
Memcache, though.
It's not shared across
instances.
So if one instance gets shut
down because it hasn't been
receiving enough requests or
it's not needed, that memory
will disappear.
But it's an important tool in
your tool belt when your
caching things to use
local memory.
It can be heaps faster than
Memcache, heaps more reliable,
with the proviso that
it will disappear.
The third technique I want to
talk about it concurrency.
And this is where Go
really shines.
And this is where it
really excels as
compared to other runtimes.
Concurrency is where you can
decompose what your app is
doing into independently
executing things.
So even though Go on App Engine
is, at the moment,
bound to a single CPU thread,
concurrency allows you to
decompose your program so that
you can write very simple
chunks of code that are
run concurrently.
They might not run
in parallel.
But while one is blocked on an
API request, another one will
immediately start running.
And in our Gopher Mart scenario,
this would be as if
a checkout gopher needs to get
a price check on an item and
then can immediately start
scanning the other items.
If you walk into a regular
supermarket, you don't see
somebody waiting for a price
check, and then just standing
there waiting, getting the
price check back and then
doing the other items.
They go on and do more things.
And so that's concurrent work.
So let me take a bit of our code
from our example app that
was poorly written by me, and
let's make it better and
faster by using concurrency.
So here might be a little chunk
of code that needs to
look up all the entities
of two Datastore kinds.
In this case, we have a list and
an item kind, and we want
to get all the items of each.
This is a straight line code,
and it's very slow.
If each query takes a certain
amount of time, the total time
to run this bit of code
is going to be
the sum of the times.
It'd be much, much quicker if we
could run them in parallel.
And since most of your web apps,
most of all web apps,
tend to be bound waiting on API
calls to come back from
various other services, this
is an easy way to speed up
most requests by doing
things concurrently.
So here all we've had to do is
kick off two Go routines to
run these queries, and they'll
be independently waiting.
Then we're using an error
channel to signal
when they're done.
Hopefully it'll send back
nil if there's no error.
And then, down at the bottom,
we just wait for
both of them to return.
This means that instead of two
requests summing together, we
now end up taking time roughly
equivalent of the maximum
length of either of them.
So that's going to be strictly
less than the sum in any
reasonable scenario.
So this is a very simple flavor
of concurrency in Go.
This is far from
sophisticated.
So I'll commend you, my
colleague, Sameer Ajmani, and
his talk this afternoon where
he'll be talking about some
advanced Go concurrency
patterns.
So if this kind of thing sounds
interesting to you, and
it does to me, get along
to that talk.
The next technique I
want to talk about
is controlling variance.
And in our Gopher Mart,
we have a 10
items or fewer queue.
But occasionally a gopher comes
by when they've got a
few more than 10 items, if
you know what I mean.
And while most gophers might
take a millisecond to process,
one in 100 might take
10 times that.
It might take 100 milliseconds,
for example.
And this is a very
common thing.
It could be due to
the request.
So in our Gopher Mart situation,
it might just be
the occasional gopher with a
very, very big cart full of
items, whereas most carts
only have a few items.
But it can also be due
to the infrastructure
underneath your app.
And the App Engine
infrastructure is great.
It's highly scalable.
It's fast.
It's dependable.
It's very reliable.
But it's not perfect.
Occasionally you'll be doing
Datastore requests, and
they'll be going 20
milliseconds, 25 milliseconds,
22 milliseconds, be really
reliably quick.
But then a small fraction of it
might take half a second.
And the consequences of this
kind of variance can cascade
through our system if
it's sophisticated.
If your app needs to do several
things in a sequence,
where each one depends on the
results of the previous one
such that these things can't be
done concurrently, then a
variance in one affects
the whole pipeline.
And the perfect storm of
variance affecting all your
items in this sequence
will blow out your
request time hugely.
Variable requests also make
scheduling a lot harder.
And this something that I
haven't really touched on
much, and I won't go into
too much detail.
But the App Engine scheduler
needs to take a guess as to
which App Engine instance
each request will
best be served by.
It's got a balance
across them.
If it's getting too much
traffic, it'll start up new
instances and so on
automatically.
But it needs to usually, for the
most part, take a guess as
to which instance will be idle
the first so it can add that
request to that App Engine
instance's queue.
The less predictable your
request handling is, though,
the hard it is to do that
kind of prediction.
So if there's variance in your
request handling, the
scheduler, though it is great
and highly sophisticated, will
start to make mistakes
more often.
And so you might get your
instances being a bit
overbalanced.
You know, one handling 100
requests for only two being
handled by another, and so on.
So it might make
mistakes there.
And this will lead to you
requiring more app instances,
more instance hours, which will
lead to a higher bill if
you've got billing enabled.
So all we want to do
is control the
variance of our requests.
We want to put an upper limit
on how long we're going to
spend doing certain
operations.
I'll point you at this paper
publishing the ACM by two guys
from Google.
This goes into a lot of detail
about some techniques for
controlling this kind of
variance, in particular, long
tail latency.
And it's geared around machines
in a data center
doing server processing.
But the same techniques apply
to web apps that are
processing requests as well.
So I'm going to discuss just
one way of doing this.
So I'll point you to that paper
to go into more detail.
Storing in Memcache is usually
an optimization.
So as I mentioned before,
Memcache is not perfect, and
it won't necessarily guarantee
to hold your data.
If you need guaranteed data
storage, you need to store it
in something like Datastore.
But Memcache, as a result, is
usually an optimization.
And optimizations by their
nature are usually optional.
So what we want to do is, in our
request, we don't want to
spend huge amounts of time,
unlimited amounts of time, on
these things that aren't
strictly required.
So in our Gopher Mart scenario,
we might be doing a
bunch of request processing, and
then we might not want to
store those fresh fruit items
that we've looked up out of
the booklet in Memcache.
But we don't want to spend
an infinite amount
of time doing that.
You know, Memcache might be
briefly down, or it might be
running a bit slowly,
or whatever it is.
So we want to cap the amount
of time that we'll spend
waiting on it.
And here's the first approach
that does not work.
In our request handler, we
might just kick off a
memcache.Set operation at the
bottom in its own Go routine.
We think, that's great.
My request will immediately
return and Memcache will do
its thing behind the scenes.
But the problem here is that,
in the App Engine model, the
scope of your context objects
are bound to the
scope of the request.
So any API calls have to be
done while the request is
still going.
And as soon as the HTTP handler
returns here, your
context will be invalidated, and
any outstanding API calls
will be canceled.
So we can't do this.
Here's what we can do.
We can again kick off the
Memcache operation
concurrently.
And then we use a
done channel.
And this done channel is going
to be signaled on as soon as
that Memcache operation
returns.
And then down at the bottom,
we use Go's concurrency
primitive called a Select block
to wait for one of two
channel operations to happen.
The first one, if the
Memcache operation
finishes, we go through.
There's nothing in the select
body, so nothing's going to
happen but will just immediately
return from the
HTTP handler.
So in the likely event that
Memcache is its usual quick
and speedy self, this
has no overhead.
The second case, though,
is if we end up
waiting a bit too long.
And Memcache will usually be 1
millisecond, 2 milliseconds,
depending on what you're doing
with it and how much data is
being sloshed around.
If it takes more than 3
milliseconds that we've
decided we want to wait for,
time.After will signal on the
channel the returns after
3 milliseconds.
So at that point, if Memcache
takes too long, that second
channel will be signal on we
drop as like we've and return
and that point the Memcache
operation will be canceled.
It will fail.
It will go away.
And we've returned
to the user.
So using these kind of
primitives to timeout waiting
for things that are optional
is a useful technique to
ensure high-performance
consistently.
So here's an overview
of where we went.
We started off with a very
poorly written app on my
behalf that did very
simplicity code.
It just did a sequence of
Datastore operations, and then
a mail.send and took nearly
400 milliseconds.
Just by applying two of the
techniques that we did today,
we got it down to only
70 milliseconds.
So a dramatic speedup with
very little work.
Once you've got experience
with it, these kinds of
transformations will take
5 to 10 minutes.
So it can very quickly done.
So let me sum up what
we covered today.
The first thing is to
find the performance
bottlenecks in your code.
Don't rely on your own
intuition, because your
intuition will fool
you reliably.
And, even if your intuition is
correct one day, it might be
incorrect down the road.
So the important thing to note
is to measure, and measure,
and measure, and keep coming
back to measuring to
understand your app's
performance.
Then the five techniques
that I covered--
deferring work--
moving work that doesn't have
to happen during the request
out of the scope of the request,
probably by using
Task Queue or the
delay package.
Batching--
so doing multiple operations
in one shot.
Caching--
so memoizing data.
It might be in the Datastore.
It might be in Memcache.
It might be in local memory.
it might be even in other
places I haven't mentioned, so
that you can check them later
and speed up those parts
of your app.
Concurrency--
so decomposing the work that
you're doing into independent
pieces that can be combined.
And finally controlling variance
to cut off the long
tail of latency so that your
app requests can be
consistently quick rather than
very, very occasionally taking
a bit too much time.
So finally here's a bunch
of links to the
Go project in general.
There's a heap of documentation
on there.
You can download Go,
try it out online.
The second link is to the
Go on App Engine docs.
The third one links to these
talk's slides, plus my really
bad source code for the Gopher
Mart app and its revisions,
and then to the Appstats package
that was written by
Matt Jibson, who
might be here.
He did really good
work on that.
There's more Go sessions coming
up later today and
tomorrow, so get
along to that.
In particular, I'll be at the
Office Hours this level at the
Cloud Sandbox if you have any
particular questions about Go
on App Engine, whether
performance or otherwise.
So come along and have a chat.
So with that, I'll thank you for
coming again, and we can
take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Can you hear me?
OK.
So I've been using Go for a
while now, but I haven't used
App Engine yet.
So quick question on the
control variance.
DAVID SYMONDS: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Instead of trying to
set it in Memcache right then
and there, could you not put it
in a global channel and do
a select on it with a timeout,
and then handle it outside?
DAVID SYMONDS: In a
global channel?
You mean like in a
global variable?
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
DAVID SYMONDS: Yeah, you can
store there right away.
The downside of that is that it
will only be used for that
app instance.
So the memory for each
app instance is only
accessible to the app.
AUDIENCE: That wasn't
the question, sir.
So the operation of setting it
in Memcache, instead of doing
it in that handle, could you
not put it in a channel and
then pick it up from there
with a worker?
Just set it in.
DAVID SYMONDS: You could.
The only way to make API calls
is during a request.
So you can't kick off a Go
routine that does its own
thing independent of requests.
You could put it in a channel
and in a later request pull
things off the channel and do
it at that point, or use a
Task Queue or use backends
to do that kind of thing.
Yeah, that would work.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID SYMONDS: One
from this side.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Nelson from [INAUDIBLE].
Can you comment on a couple
techniques people are using to
make Go applications more
efficient in pricing compared
to Java and Python?
DAVID SYMONDS: So I mentioned
that Go apps get compiled to
native code.
They're binaries.
That results in them starting
up really quickly.
So every time a new request
starts coming in and the
infrastructure decides to spin
up new requests, it'll be a
lot faster load.
It's just got to run
a single program.
It doesn't have to start a
virtual machine, page in a
bunch of modules, or
whatever it is.
So it'll be really
fast to start.
That means that that single
instance starts up quickly and
immediately can start
doing work.
If you suddenly get an onslaught
of traffic, in other
runtimes, you might have to
start up a bunch of instance.
That'll take a little while,
but then they can deal with
all the traffic that's
coming in.
The second main way is that you
have a lot more control
over the memory that
you are using.
Go is a very hands-on
language.
It gives you a lot more control
over things like
memory lag and so on.
So you can allocate a slab of
bytes, and you've got that
slab of bytes.
You don't have any overhead
for that.
So using those kinds of things,
if you're intensively
using your application
instance's memory, you can
feed a lot more in, say an F1
instance, than you can in,
say, other runtime.
AUDIENCE: Why did you use
a buffered channel
in that last example?
DAVID SYMONDS: Good question.
AUDIENCE: Is that so the
Go routine dies?
DAVID SYMONDS: Yeah, I use a
buffered channel in case the
timeout happens.
So if the timeout happens,
nothing's going to be reading
from that done channel.
So if the timeout happens,
nothing will be reading from
that buffered channel, which
means when the Memcache call
does return, it will block
unless I buffer it.
So I buffer it so that if that
timeout happens, the Memcache
can return and still do a
channel operation to a channel
that will just disappear.
But then that Go routine
will exit and
won't be hanging around.
AUDIENCE: So there could
be a memory leak if
you don't do that?
DAVID SYMONDS: You have
a Go routine leak.
Yeah, that would be a memory
leak in that case if you
didn't have a buffered
channel.
AUDIENCE: It's not tied
to the parent channel,
or the parent request?
DAVID SYMONDS: No.
AUDIENCE: I have a few
short questions.
Thank you.
NDB has caching built into it.
Is there any plan to
do that for Go?
DAVID SYMONDS: Yeah, there's a
couple of external packages
that have been written that
provide an NBD-type layer.
I can't remember them off the
top of my head, but they're
out there, and I can look them
up if you want to ask me at
Office Hours.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And also you seem to imply--
it's only tied to
one CPU, right?
But Go is really powerful
with multiple CPUs.
You seem to imply that in the
future that won't be the case?
DAVID SYMONDS: So each of your
app instances runs CPU bound
on a single thread.
So while it's doing an RPC to
do a Datastore fetch or
whatever, it will switch
to other things.
So it's got concurrency
in that respect.
But we only have one CPU
thread running at any
one time for now.
AUDIENCE: It could change
in the future?
DAVID SYMONDS: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you.
DAVID SYMONDS: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Python and Java
Runtime have a unit testing
package with App Engine APIs.
Now, Go has no new test package
for App Engine APIs.
Do you have any plan to?
DAVID SYMONDS: Yes, we realize
the testing story for Go on
App Engine is weak, and we have
plans to improve that in
the near future.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Just a question again on the
multi-threading side.
If I take an instance with two
cores, what's happening there?
One of them sits idle
all the time?
DAVID SYMONDS: The instance
classes are based on
virtualized CPU gigahertz rather
than number of cores.
Sorry, I'm not sure off the top
of my head what it would
do if you were on two cores
in that instance.
It's possible that you would run
multiple instances on that
machine instead.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID SYMONDS: Any
more questions?
Yup.
OK.
Thank you very much for coming.